après claude kern et jacques bigot
permettait un troisième sénateur
alsacien demeurant à strasbourg de
s'exprimer après le drame qui a
endeuillé endeuillé sa ville au nom du
groupe l'est républicain je veux à mon
tour m'incliner devant les victimes et
dire notre compassion à l'égard de leurs
familles de leurs proches
je veux également réaffirmer notre
soutien et rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre qui injustement malmené ces
derniers temps font un remarquable
travail de protection de la population
tout au long de l'année mais
particulièrement dans ces périodes de
fin d'année strasbourg capitale des
droits de l'homme capitale de l'europe
des valeurs comme dit son maire a été
touché au coeur qui plus est elle l'a
été pendant son marché de noël dont on
sait qu'il n'est pas un marché de noël
comme les autres ils constituent pour
les alsaciens une tradition
multiséculaire de joie de fraternité et
de paix le symbole mes chers collègues
efforts et la blessure est profonde mais
je voudrais ici affirmé solennellement
que malgré la barbarie qui les frappent
les alsaciens ne renoncerons pas pour
autant apporter leurs valeurs
d'humanisme que d'aucuns voudraient leur
voir disparaître
je voudrais ensuite vous dire monsieur
le premier ministre après avoir pris
connaissance du parcours de vie de ce
terroriste qui à 29 ans a déjà été
condamné
27 fois que la population en a assez de
l'arepa de la répétition de cette chaîne
mortifère qui commence par le délinquant
par la délinquance de droit commun se
poursuit par de la récidive puis de la
multirécidive 27 fois j'ai dit puis de
la radicalisation en prison puis fichier
s est enfin trop souvent la tentation du
passage à l'acte terroriste
les exemples sont nombreux je ne veux
pas les citer ici pour ne pas faire bien
sûr la promotion de leurs auteurs le
premier ministre on sait que 450 détenus
radicaliser seront libérés l'année
prochaine faut-il craindre pour 2019
autant de passages à l'acte quels sont
les moyens que vous comptez mettre en
oeuvre pour répondre à cela et pouvez
vous ici monsieur le premier ministre
prendre l'engagement que pas un centime
de crédit
que le projet de budget 2010 9 affectant
la sécurité aux forces de l'ordre ne
sera redéployé je vous remercie pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur on avait la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs center monsieur le le sénateur
chacun sait ici ce lien indéfectible qui
lie un élu à son territoire chacun s'est
du coup la souffrance plus forte encore
de celles et ceux qui sont exprimés qui
sont les élus de ces territoires
mais chacun sait aussi que quand on est
parlementaire on a cette fierté de la
nation et que la nation est attaqué on a
la fierté de se sentir proche de vous et
tu territoire que vous représentez je
voudrais monsieur le sénateur d'abord
revient en quelques mots sur le parcours
de cet individu
effectivement dès l'âge de dix ans sans
que ce soit inscrit parce qu'il n'a pas
eu de condamnation il avait fait montre
de violence de violence vis-à-vis de
l'autorité familiale
et puis au fil de sa vie il s'est montré
comme un individu particulièrement
violents ils étaient condamnés plusieurs
fois en france en allemagne il a
systématiquement purger les peines pour
lequel il a été condamné
et puis vous l'avais dit il ya une
graduation dans la violence et il était
susceptible d'être arrêté avant-hier
matin pour complicité dans une tentative
d'homicide et donc on voit bien comment
la violence de cet individu est devenu
au fond son quotidien
rien n'indique qu'il ait été radicalisé
en prison par contre c'est en prison que
nous avons détecté sa radicalisation et
c'est la raison pour laquelle à la
sortie de sa prison il était suivie
identifiée c'est l'intérêt du fichier s
comme msf espère t il a été identifiée
et suivie en particulier par les
services de la dg à 6 j ai répondu tout
à l'heure et donc évidemment il faut que
nous ayons les moyens nécessaires pour
continuer à suivre systématiquement
celles et ceux qui présentent ces
risques mais je vous rappelle que
présenter ces risques n'est pas une
incrimination pénale sur lequel nous
pouvons intervenir ces raisons pour
laquelle le gouvernement presse les
gouvernements précédents et le
gouvernement actuel ont fait le choix de
doter de moyens exceptionnels notamment
les services de la dg assis avec le
recrutement de plus de 1900 personnes 22
5 millions d'euros par exemple sont
prévus pour la modernisation des
systèmes de renseignements qui sont
nécessaires pour assurer ce suivi vous a
évoqué la question budgétaire
et puis il nous faut aussi agir dans
l'immédiat et c'est toute une série de
mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement est sous l'autorité du
premier ministre
en passant en alerte attentats et le
premier ministre pour conclure a indiqué
hier soir qu'il y aura un renfort
outre les 500 premiers militaires qui
ont été mobilisés dans les 24 heures qui
ont suivi l'attaqué dont strasbourg a
fait l'objet mais du coup 500 militaires
déployés sur l'ensemble des marchés de
noël de l'est parisien et j'ai couru
vers le christ matin que c'était le cas
le premier sera décidé de porter ce
nombre à 1800 qui seront dans les heures
qui viennent mobilisés sur l'ensemble du
territoire national je vous remercie
monsieur richard merci monsieur le
ministre pour ce cette réponse je
voudrais simplement vous dire que la
réponse
les réponses au terrorisme doit
s'attaquer à ses causes
sans une lutte déterminée contre la
délinquance de droit commun sans
l'abandon voire l'acceptation de
certains communautarismes sans
affirmation dès le plus jeune âge plus
jeune âge dans les écoles de notre
identité de notre culture nous n'y
arriverons pas et la parole